he pulls me over to the side of the
driveway he then states he wanted to
taze me if he had a Taser and would have
shot and killed me if he had drawn his
weapon and he would have been fully
justified in killing me ever since I was
a little child my parents have instilled
in me a love for the values that the
United States holds dear my parents came
to the United States from brutal
military dictatorship and they chose the
United States because of our
Constitution Nicolas Aquino was born and
raised in the United States after his
family fled Paraguay
he says his understanding of his
family's difficult past made him want to
give back for the freedoms the u.s.
provided that is one of many factors in
in terms of why I wanted to serve this
country was so that I could uphold those
ideals that I could fight that I could
give back to the community and make sure
that they keep those freedoms when I was
really little probably about 3 I went to
my first Air Show I've always loved the
Air Force
I remember just wanting to be a part of
this country and serving it Aquino
attends the Naval Postgraduate School in
Monterey California and in many ways has
become quite the poster child for the
military so when he found out there was
a warrant out for his arrest he was
shocked
I never was arrested charged cited
booked nothing I've never even had to
had a ticket he found out he was being
charged with resisting arrest during an
incident that happened in December of
2013 an incident in which he believes he
was the victim one of akeno's neighbors
had reported seeing a suspicious person
at akeno's address aquino had been
living there for a few months but the
neighbor was rarely around and didn't
recognize him
sheriff's deputy ivan Rodriguez followed
up on the call and checked out the
residents but Aquino said the officer
didn't provide any identification when
he went out to greet him there are
plenty of police impersonators out there
a badge
online cost 60 bucks to get so my
question to him was excute excuse me who
are you
and why you're here he said he was
investigating suspicious activity in the
area I asked him am I being detained
he said yes so I was like okay my name
is Nicolas Aquino I live right here how
long am I being detained
for what are the charges and do you have
a warrant everything that Nicolas was
doing to me is sort of like textbook
like okay I'm going to be respectful I'm
going to answer questions but I'm also
going to insist that you answer
questions for me because I am within my
rights on my property to ask these
questions akeno's lawyer Steven liner
says that nothing Nicolas did suggested
aggression and the arrest report agrees
the officer though he couldn't be
reached for comment wrote in the report
that the male looked to have a normal to
slightly nervous demeanor but did not
immediately seem confrontational or
aggressive but that he later asked in a
confrontational tone if he was being
detained
the officer apparent he appears to have
been offended at the idea that a citizen
would question his authority at the
officers request aquino showed his
military ID and other forms of
identification but the officer was still
unconvinced and moved to physically
detain him he just grabbed my wrist
without any warning without provocation
put me in a front headlock choke the
technical term is a front guillotine
slam my head into the ground so
currently I still have fluid buildup in
in the back of my right ear right head
contusion both arms abrasions and
contusions on the elbows knees hip right
hip using force should have been the
last resort unless there was some reason
to believe that Nicolas was doing
something that was
you know harm him at that moment and
there was nothing that he was doing that
would cause that eventually Aquino was
able to convince the officer that he did
in fact live there the officer did not
apologize he pulls me over to the side
of the driveway and he does basic victim
victim-blaming so he says it was my
fault for not knowing my neighbors he
then states he wanted to tase me if he
had a Taser and would have shot and
killed me if he had drawn his weapon and
he would have been fully justified in
killing me I think that sometimes police
officers are so used to being in control
of every situation that just any small
amount of perceived resistance from a
citizen causes them to treat them like
they are you know a criminal there was
no reason to physically detain me or
arrest me as far as putting me in a
chokehold
even if my muscles tensed the automatic
reaction to being choked is to tense up
reach for the neck yet the DA used this
perceived tension as a springboard for
the charges against Aquino resisting
arrest and obstructing a peace officer
are we supposed to just bend over and
excuse my friends just take it just
because a person is on a power trip and
feels that he can bully you into into
submission minor says no citizens need
to ask these questions and stand up for
their rights we have to exercise them we
have to hold a police officer
accountable make sure that he or she
does their job properly
that's all nicholas was doing and we
feel that this is an opportunity for all
of us to talk about how it is that
citizens have an absolute right to ask
questions and that police officers
should be respectful and civil and
and act lawfully which means not using
force unless it really is called for
liner says that the public outcry on
behalf of Aquino helped force the DA's
hand and the charges have since been
dropped though they still strongly
defend the officer's actions the DA's
office declined reasons request for an
interview but said in a subsequent
statement that the deputy sheriff had
lawfully detained captain Aquino I think
it's clear by the public reaction to
this case is that there's a sense among
the public that law enforcement
oversteps their bounds or oversteps
proper procedure in the way that they
deal with us getting the charges dropped
is a victory but Nicholas plans to
continue fighting he is filing a claim
for civil damages against Monterey
County to cover his legal expenses in
addition to physical and emotional costs